>> Bret: GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THAT.
CASEY STEGALL LIVE IN DALLAS.
CASEY, THANKS.
CONGRESSIONAL LAWMAKERS ARE
TRYING TO PUSH A CORONAVIRUS
PACKAGE ACROSS THE FINISH LINE
TONIGHT.
IT WILL TRY AGAIN TONIGHT.
CHAD PERGRAM TELLS US WHERE
THINGS STAND THIS EVENING AT
THIS HOUR FROM CAPITOL HILL.
GOOD EVENING, CHAD.
>> GOOD EVENING.
CONGRESS WILL LIKELY WORK TO
FINALIZE THE COVID RELIEF
PACKAGE.
MITCH McCONNELL SAYS ’TIS THE
SEASON FOR CONGRESS TO FINISH UP
UP.
>> WELL, WE AND CONGRESS ARE NO
STRANGERS TO THE DECEMBER
FUNDING DEADLINES OR THE
CLIFFHANGER.
IN THAT RESPECT, THE SITUATION
WE FACE NOW IS FAMILIAR.
>> A $900 BILLION AID BILL DAYS
AGO THAT DETAILS MATTER.
WORKING OUT DIRECT STIMULUS
CHECKS IS COMPLICATED.
ONE ISSUE THAT REMAINS, MONEY
FOR STATE AND LOCAL DEMOCRATS.
REPUBLICANS WARNED THAT THEY
COULD USE IT TO REFUND PAYMENT
THROUGH THE BACK DOOR.
LIBERALS CONTEND THE BILL
DOESN’T DO ENOUGH.
>> RIGHT NOW IN THE MIDST OF A
TERRIBLE PANDEMIC WHERE THE
ECONOMY IS AND DISASTROUS SHAPE,
ALL WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IS
$900 BILLION.
THAT IS AN INADEQUATE SUM OF
MONEY TO DO WHAT HAS TO BE DONE.
>> THIS COULD SET THE TABLE FOR
ANOTHER BILL UNDER
PRESIDENT-ELECT BIDEN NEXT YEAR.
IT IS LIKELY THEY WILL HAVE TO
APPROVE A BAND-AID SPENDING BILL
TO AVOID THE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN